bien entramos ahora al problema número 7
el problema número 7 que tiene un
triángulo muy parecido a éste
déjame hacer aquí el triángulo tengo un
triángulo muy parecido a éste tengo un
triángulo y entonces por aquí está la
base por aquí está la base por aquí está
la base por aquí está la altura así que
dibujemos la altura dibujemos la altura
de este triángulo a la altura no está
perfectamente bien hecha pero creo que
se entiende se entiende a dónde voy
porque me dicen que este triángulo tiene
a primero tienen las siguientes letras
este punto de aquí es x este punto de
aquí es z y este punto de acá es pie
este punto de acahay en la altura es h
y esta forma un ángulo recto muy bien y
me dicen que x en el valor de x es 6
séptimos de h es decir que esta
distancia de aquí acá es lo mismo que 6
séptimos 6 séptimos de h ok y para que
me dan esto porque lo que me preguntan
es cuánto vale el área de este triángulo
el área de este triángulo que por cierto
si nosotros recordamos cómo sacar el
área de un triángulo pues es muy fácil
es un medio la base por la altura el
área de un triángulo es un medio la base
por la altura y nosotros sabemos que la
base es 6 séptimos de h por lo tanto
vamos a sustituir el área va a ser igual
a un médium de la base pero la base son
6 séptimos de la altura esto es lo que
vale la base no lo olvidemos esto es lo
que va justo aquí y ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por la altura ok y que me
queda de esto bueno
el área el área que depende de la altura
el área que depende de la altura aquí es
igual
bueno pues un medio por seis séptimos
podemos reducir un poco este 2 se va con
este 6 y me quedan 33 séptimos 3
séptimos de quien de hecho por h es
decir h cuadrada el área que depende de
h es 3 séptimos de h cuadrada que por
cierto es el inciso b dice cuál es el
área como función de h y bueno es 3
séptimos de h cuadrada perfecto ya está
el problema número 7
así que movámonos al problema número 8
el problema número 8 que dice lo
siguiente
y si ha elevado a la un medio por haber
elevado al a un tercio
todo esto elevado a la potencia número 6
esto es igual a 432 a 432 lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale aborde lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale a por b
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es que
podemos utilizar las leyes de los
exponentes existe una de las leyes de
los exponentes que me dice que a m por n
esto elevado a la potencia x esto es lo
mismo que m elevado la equis por n
elevado a la equis así que vamos a
aplicarlo aquí me va a quedar a ha
elevado a la un medio esto elevado a la
sexta potencia que va a multiplicar a su
vez a b elevado a la un tercio esto
elevado a la sexta potencia y esto es
igual a 432 ahora bueno podemos
multiplicar estas dos potencias
recuerdan que hay una ley de los
exponentes que me dice que m elevado a
la n elevado a su vez a la p esto es
exactamente lo mismo que m elevado a la
n por p ok pues apliquémoslo esto me va
a quedar ha elevado a la
6 por un medio es lo mismo que 3 ha
elevado al cubo por bm elevado al a un
tercio por 6 es 2b elevado al cuadrado
esto es lo mismo que 432
y qué podemos hacer por aquí lo que se
me ocurre es que podemos factorizar una
a esto es lo mismo que a que multiplica
a cuadrada por b cuadrada o dicho de
otra manera esto es lo mismo que a que
multiplica por b elevado al cuadrado y
esto lo que me va a servir bueno esto es
lo mismo que 432 432 es decir aquí estoy
diciendo que tengo un número un número
que multiplica a un número elevado al
cuadrado a un cuadrado perfecto y esto
tiene que ser igual a 432 y bueno
nosotros sabemos que las preguntas de
ese tema no siempre son muy difíciles
por lo tanto vamos a ver qué pasa si yo
he vivido 432 entre dos a ver cuánto es
esto
si a vale dos vamos a poner aquí si a
vale dos entonces cuánto es 432 entre 2
entre 2 pues aquí me va a quedar 2
sobran 01 sobre 126 216 es decir que
aporte el aporte elevado al cuadrado
tiene que ser igual a 216 y a poco 216
es un cuadrado perfecto
pues veamos
a ver cuántos 16 por 16 vamos a ponerlo
aquí
16 16 por 16 6 por 6 36 y llevamos 36
por unas seis y tres son nueve y aquí me
queda 16 10 me queda 6 9 y 6 son 5 15
llevamos una 256 y 256 no es lo mismo
que 216 por lo tanto por aquí no va a 14
por 14 veamos 14 por 14 4 por 4 16 por
aquí vamos bien y llevamos 14 por 14 y
15 14 y si yo sumo es 196 tampoco me
sirve y de hecho creo que es 216 no es
un cuadrado perfecto por lo tanto creo
que por aquí no va a no puede valer 2
entonces vamos a ver si puede valer otro
número pero ya no tengo espacio
déjame borrar todo esto vamos a borrar
todo esto de aquí no me sirve por
ahorita no me sirve entonces lo voy a
quitar y también estoy aquí esto tampoco
me sirve ok vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasa si a vale 3 si a vale 3 si a vale 3
432 es divisible entre 3 a su menos 432
ahmed a 79
por lo tanto 432 es invisible entre 3 y
cuánto es 432 entre 3 cuánto es esto
veamos que de una vez uno por 3 334
menos 3 es uno y después bajo este 3 y
me cabe 4 veces 4 por 3 12 me sobra 1
bajo este 2 y otras 4 veces 4 por 3 es
12 sobre en cero y qué crees wow
ya llegamos en la respuesta ya te diste
cuenta que no sale del resultado no sale
144 esto quiere decir que a por b al
cuadrado tiene que ser igual a 144
o pensar que 144 es un cuadrado
perfectos lo cual es cierto
144 es lo mismo que 12 elevado al
cuadrado o dicho otra manera a x b es lo
mismo que 12 porque cuando a 12 lo elevó
al cuadrado me da 144 a ver veamos
vámonos con calma si a vale 3 me
quedaría que esto es lo mismo que 3 por
un aporte elevado al cuadrado pero a por
b es lo mismo que 12 12 elevado al
cuadrado y si te das cuenta esto es lo
mismo que 432 es decir que estamos bien
cuando a vale 3 entonces a volver vale
12 que es justo lo que queríamos saber y
vamos a ver si estas nuestras respuestas
a por ve igual a 12 esto es lo mismo que
el inciso b si está en nuestras
respuestas por lo tanto una de nuestras
posibles respuestas es que a por vez sea
12 ya está perfecto así que ya tenemos
aquí el problema número 8 vamos a hacer
el problema número 9 déjenme borrar todo
esto y vámonos al problema número
9 el problema número 9 dice cuál es el
mayor número de tres dígitos que tiene
como factor a 10
cuál es el mayor de tres dígitos que
tiene como factor a 10 déjame cambiar la
herramienta y vamos a ponerlo por acá y
necesito un número de tres dígitos es
decir que el número debe de estar entre
100 y
y 999 entre 100 y 999 y además que tenga
como factor a 10 y bueno lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que todo número que
tiene como factor a 10 deben de acabar
en 0 por ejemplo 10 20 30 40 todos estos
acaban en cero y tienen como un factor a
10 por lo tanto el número más grande de
tres dígitos que termine en cero pues es
el número que esté más cercano a 999 que
termine en cero es decir 990 y esta es
la respuesta del problema número 9 ya
está es más creo que hasta que me acabe
el problema número 10 el problema número
10 que dice lo siguiente la preparación
de un platillo típico mexicano para 20
personas necesita 4 kilogramos de
frijoles
voy a ponerlo aquí a este platillo para
20 personas para 20 personas personas
necesita
a 4 kilogramos de frijoles 4 kilogramos
de frijoles
goles con esta proporción con esta misma
proporción cuantos kilogramos de
frijoles se necesitan para preparar el
mismo platillo a 150 personas
lo que quiero es preparar este mismo
platillo a 150 personas personas y como
lo que nos piden es la misma proporción
la misma razón pues podemos hacer una
regla de tres es decir que lo que
necesitamos saber es x kilogramos de
frijoles de frijoles aquí y entonces
utilicemos una regla de tres este por
este entre este este por este y a esto
lo voy a dividir entre este y que me va
a quedar 150 por 4 150 por 4 está
dividido entre 20 esto es lo que va a
valer
ok y cuánto es esto 150 por 4 600 600
entre 20 este 0 y este 0 se van y me
queda simple y sencillamente 30 30
kilogramos de frijoles es lo que vamos a
necesitar para preparar el mismo
platillo típico mexicano pero esta vez a
150 personas con la misma proporción así
que ya está
pasemos a los siguientes problemas 910
am
vamos el problema número 11 el problema
número 11 cuando el entero par positivo
n le agregamos el 50% de su valor a n es
un entero par y positivo ya esté entero
par positivo le vamos a agregar el 50%
de su valor es decir punto 5 por n
cuando le agregamos el 50% de su valor
el resultado está entre 10 y 20 el
resultado de esto está entre 10 y 20
así que vamos a ponerlo a n + punto 5 n
esto está entre 20 y entre 10 está entre
10 y 20 ok
aquí ya tenemos una desigualdad cual es
un posible valor para n perfecto lo que
quiero saber es uno de los posibles
valores para n y para esto
se me ocurre que de aquí podemos
simplificar esta desigualdad primero me
quedaría 10
esto es menor que en más punto 5 n que
esto es lo mismo que 1.5 n 1.5 n pero
esto es lo mismo que tres medios de n
tres medios de n entonces lo voy a
escribir como tres medios de n y esto a
su vez tiene que ser menor que 20 menor
que 20 y ahora si te das cuenta aquí
tenemos una desigualdad entonces podemos
multiplicar toda esta desigualdad por
dos tercios
voy a multiplicar toda esta desigualdad
por dos tercios por dos tercios aquí
por dos tercios aquí también y aquí
también lo voy a multiplicar por dos
tercios por dos tercios aquí de tal
manera que me aquí me va a quedar dos
tercios por diez esto es lo mismo que
veinte tercios
esto es más pequeño que estos dos se van
y me va a quedar solamente n y esto a su
vez tiene que ser más pequeño que
cuarenta tercios que cuarenta tercios y
bueno veinte tercios es más o menos como
seis puntos y algo seis punto algo algo
al no no importa eso tiene que ser menor
que n que a su vez tiene que ser menor
que 40 sobre 3 a 40 sobre 3 es 13 punto
y algo ok es decir que n n además de ser
un entero par y positivo y bueno aquí se
nota que debe ser positivo tiene que
estar entre 6 y algo y 13 y algo o dicho
otra manera tiene que estar entre 7 y
aquí no puedo quedar con el 3 entre 7 y
13 cualquier entero par que esté entre 7
y 13 nos va a servir para cumplir esta
desigualdad
podríamos tomarnos no sé el 10 es buena
opción el buena opción
el 2 es buena opción todos estos son
bastantes buenas opciones para que
cumplan esta desigualdad de un principio
y bueno puedes tomarte tu tiempo para
probar que en efecto cualquiera de estos
tres va a funcionar en esta desigualdad
pero a mí ya se me acabó el tiempo así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo